watch people die inside really Felix
it's not like I've watched your channel
for two years already I don't need any
more of that before this video begins I
have a quick little announcement that's
right everybody I'm talking about the
cam bling you don't know what this is
basically what this candling does it
turns any camera whether it's DSLR or a
camcorder or anyone any camera that has
an HDMI output plug it in and you got it
as a USB to your computer Hey look there
I am you can see me live it's pretty
cool
and you know even on the stream bank I
can hit record right there and it's
recording how cool is that
Elgato check it out stream deck the link
description enjoy the video I will not
stand for the cyber bullying anymore
this is enough I am saying no hashtag
stop cyber beam whatever I'm gonna wear
my favorite sunglasses to protect myself
in this video let's review people dying
on the inside okay that's epic at that
moment she realized how much she hated
her job she just looks embarrassing
alright embarrass that's English I want
people to die on the inside stop at
YouTube do monetization I meant on the
inside it's different the greatest
moment in TV history was when Jamie
Oliver showed children how McNuggets are
made and smugly said now who would still
eat this and literally everyone put
their hands up and he looked really sad
this is epic style that I was talking
about people being disappointed people
giving up on club living this is what I
want this is amping politician brutally
I've seen this he doesn't get dead
inside he gets oh yang side look at him
look at him that's a no yang
sideface listen he sees it he goes yeah
he goes yeah epic style stop wasting my
time I want done why is it so hard for
people to get it don't waste my time
Roy more spokesman finds out you don't
have to swear on a Bible to become
elected official judge Moore has also
said that he doesn't think a Muslim
member see I don't know who is who here
so this will be interesting to see who
will have the dead inside face my bed is
on the left one rooms I had to swear on
a Bible you have to swear on a Bible to
be an elected official in the United
States of America he alleges that a
Muslim cannot do that ethically swearing
on the Bible you don't actually have to
swear on a Christian Bible you can swear
on anything really did you don't know
that that's the face that's the face I
want to see yay yes man thank you
that was awesome isn't it great to see
people suffer pick one buddy
is the dog gonna become dead insane
do
[Music]
[Applause]
ah did you realize what cover I was
doing there at great
hey in two seconds randomly smile
intensely
[Music]
Oh hide it don't look at me like that I
didn't do nothing I didn't know oh it's
making me so uncomfortable you can tell
that they look up dating sites sometimes
when models have to wear something they
don't like it's always glasses it's
always like hey can you wear this dumb
glasses and smile okay just me a victim
of circumstances all right what are we
got oh my god it's a song it's the same
song I'm saying that's the song of dead
inside
[Music]
[Laughter]
the best dead inside is when you're
already dead inside it's a double dead
inside as I like to call it a dead
squared inside it's quite rare but it
happens to everyone at least once
never triple dead inside trying to
remove his headset Hey Oh make it stop
please
this is not a big guys oh my god it's
still going just take it off oh my god
is still happening why is it not
stopping a prime example of why you
don't do anything ever
cuz this might happen do you not
understand the risks no is that real
can someone please give me the context
of this this is beautiful oh it's kpop
performing in North Korea Rober thinks
he's locked in Bank is it a pole is it
if someone else comes in you clearly
thought out this crime well done
beasts mode goes to basics training
beast mode is off guys beast mode is off
okay I don't like this anymore
turn off the breeze mode oh you might
think it's cruel here to stand here and
review these people suffering but what
you don't understand if they that's what
you think is that
I'm suffering with them okay finally you
understand that you're not the only one
going through these things
it's an endearing thing okay my mom gets
up and dances during baseball game why
is it that parents just get off on
embarrassing their kids why are they so
cruel why are you doing this
parents truly are despicable genuine
fear is shaking what have I done
no this this red is beautiful but when
you show somebody a funny video you've
been laughing all day at and you're
waiting for them to laugh just laugh
already you don't get it this is why you
don't show videos to thoughts
you just don't the one male attendee of
my mom's wine and painting class I'm
sure he came there on his own free will
stop judging okay he did a great job on
that he didn't even finish his painting
when you're skateboard trick is almost
perfect oh man that's sex angry girl
Fred you know this has been going on for
years - he's learned to just block it
off completely for just a moment he
thought about not getting up
oh no it's like I well I would prefer to
stay here but then I can't breathe why
do I guess I'll die he forgets he can
clap why is he clapping he broke what is
it three fingers its face - like ah damn
I forgot I can't climb I really want to
clap right now their compulsion to clap
with everyone it's just too strong life
truly is cruel yeah here's another guess
I'll die when you fall in such an
embarrassing way it's probably better
just stay down
you know that expression you fall off
the horse to get back up
sometimes just just stay down it's
better to stay down
[Music]
did he drop its but he drugged his
camera
oh my cuz he threw a stupid water bottle
alright that's a strict for watch people
die inside think I discovered a new
hobby this is great maybe like if you
enjoyed watching as well thank you guys
for watching and see you guys tomorrow
with another video hit sponsor to join
the live streams goodbye
[Music]